[Music]
one of the questions I get asked a lot
is what screenwriting books should I buy
what one is the best but I actually
think that's the wrong question to ask
because the answer I give is entirely
dependent on one thing what your
weakness is as a writer because it's
only by working on our weaknesses that
we can improve let's say you struggle
with character
they aren't believable or feel
mechanical also just a different book
than if your problem was structure or
plot so in this video I want to break
down some of my favorite screenwriting
books and the reasons I'd recommend them
and stay tuned because at the end I'll
give my opinion for the best thing you
can be reading as a screenwriter
the first is Sid fields screenplay often
consider the bible of screenwriting
books
it's an in-depth analysis of 3x
structure and a fantastic starting point
for beginners or those who struggle with
plot and structure now I've been
noticing a paradigm shift away from 3x
structure in the last few years
particularly in the TV sphere but this
method is still dominant and as such
every screenwriter should have a firm
understanding of it even if they don't
intend to use it
similar to screenplay and one of my
personal favorites is Robert McKee's
story I usually recommend this as the
second book to read after screenplay
because they complement each other it's
a little less accessible but the stuff
in here is fantastic with greater
expansion on three-act structure some
character work and useful examples of
how his techniques applied to films we
know and love and then there's what's
commonly referred to as the people
magazine of screenwriting Blake Snyder's
save the cat if you want to write
mainstream high concept blockbusters
this is the book for you it's an
entertaining read that introduces some
interesting concepts that I still use
like Pope in the pool or double
mumbo-jumbo if you don't know what those
things are check this book out now I
want to get into some books I'd
recommend if you struggle with character
character development and to some extent
dialogue because dialogue is
intrinsically linked to character often
if you have trouble with dialogue it's
rooted in a problem with the character
the first book is km Wyland's creating
character arc
this is one of my absolute favorites so
much so that I did an entire video using
her concepts and applied it to Star Wars
in it you'll learn about the three
different types of character arcs and
how a character shapes the story not the
other way around it's also a great
analysis of how your character changes
over the course of the film or how they
change the world around them highly
recommend the second is Lagos agrees the
art of dramatic writing now this is
actually a book about playwriting but a
lot of the stuff in here is transferable
for us screenwriters chiefly among them
is the idea of the tri-dimensional
character in which he argues that in
order to understand how characters react
in certain situations we must first know
three things about them there's
sociology physiology and psychology so
if you've ever gotten the note oh I
don't think the character would do that
or your characters aren't believable I'd
check out this book then there are the
books I consider outliers the first is
John troubies the anatomy of story which
offers a different approach to
storytelling that as a direct refutation
of the traditional three act structure
tired of McKee or field this is the book
for you offering new paradigm shifting
techniques on how to approach story I
also love how truly uses multiple films
as example throughout to highlight his
tools and concepts then there's
Christopher Vogler's the writer's
journey which looks at storytelling from
a place of heroic myth a character goes
into the unknown battles his or her
demons and comes back a hero the
interesting thing about the writers
journey is that it can fit in almost any
of the affer mentioned structures this
book is also great if you're stuck say
there's a problem with your script and
you just can't figure it out going
through the steps of the writers journey
can help pinpoint where your problem is
and offer solutions on how to solve it
last and certainly not least the best
thing you can be reading to better
yourself as a writer is to read other
scripts read bad ones read good ones
immerse yourself in other people's work
you'll start learning what you like what
you don't pay seing tone and other
things you can't learn from watching the
movie or reading a book as someone who
has read over a thousand scripts I can
honestly say that reading others has
been one of the greatest learning
periences I'll leave a link below where
you can find out how to access some of
these scripts and I also suggest
checking out the annual blacklist to
give you a sense of what is out there
and what is getting buzz so that's my
breakdown of my favorite screenwriting
books what are yours let me know in the
comments below I'd love your feedback
and as always thanks for watching don't
forget to Like and subscribe and hit
that Bell button keep on writing